♪ ♪
>> Tucker: OH, ANOTHER UFO
SEGMENT.
THAT'S CRAZY.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE CRAZY TO
BELIEVE THAT IS POSSIBLE.
REALLY?
IS IT ANY CRAZIER COMING OUT OF,
SAY, YOUR AVERAGE WHITE HOUSE
BRIEFING?
WITH THAT IN MIND, A FASCINATING
CONFERENCE TODAY ABOUT UFOs
AND NUCLEAR WEAPONS, AND TOOK
PLACE IN WASHINGTON.
U.S. AIR FORCE CAPTAIN WAS PART
OF AN INCIDENT IN WHICH A UFO
DISABLED TENANT NUCLEAR
MISSILES.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A LONG HISTORY
OF UFO INCIDENTS AND ENCOUNTERS,
WITH MUCH INVESTIGATION OF THAT
FROM 1947 AND EVEN EARLIER.
IN SEPTEMBER OF 1966, I WAS
MINUTEMAN LAUNCH PATROL OFFICER
AND DEPUTY COMMANDER OF A LAUNCH
CREW STATION AT THE AIR FORCE
BASE IN NORTH DAKOTA.
I WAS INVOLVED IN A UFO INCIDENT
AT THAT TIME, WHERE A FLYING
OBJECT TAMPERED WITH AND TOOK
DOWN A TOTAL OF TEN NUCLEAR
TIPPED ICBM MISSILES BY
RENDERING THEM UNWATCHABLE.
>> Tucker: TOM ROGAN IS ONE OF
THE RARE SERIOUS JOURNALISTS,
ACTUAL JOURNALISTS, IN
WASHINGTON.
HE HAS BEEN ON THE STORY FOR
YEARS IN A VERY RIGOROUS WAY.
HE IS A COLUMNIST NOW AT "THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER"" AND JOINS
US TONIGHT FOR A RECAP.
TOM, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN TODAY AT THIS
EVENT?
>> THANKS, TUCKER.
I THINK THE KEY POINT HERE IS
ALTHOUGH THESE GENTLEMEN ARE
TELLING THEIR STORIES FOR A
WHILE, NOW THEY ARE DOING
IT IN A FASHION WHERE THEY CAN
FINALLY BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY BY
MORE PEOPLE, AND FORTUNATELY
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE WERE NOT
THAT MANY JOURNALISTS THERE
TODAY BUT I THINK THE
KEY POINT IS PEOPLE WITH SOME OF
THE HIGHEST SECURITY CLEARANCES
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE COLD WAR IN
THE U.S. AIR FORCE, MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT INTER-VISUAL'S AND
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT SITES ACROSS
A PERIOD OF DECADES,
SAY UFOs INTERACTED WITH
NUCLEAR WEAPONS PLATFORMS AND
EITHER RENDERED THEM INOPERABLE
OR TOOK THEM OFF LINE.
SO SOMETHING WAS DONE BY A
TECHNOLOGICAL FORCE, AS THESE
OFFICERS WOULD SUGGEST, THAT
CANNOT BE EXPLAINED, AND THAT IN
AND OF ITSELF, SURELY, SHOULD BE
BIG NEWS, WORTHY OF SERIOUS
FURTHER INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: BY DEFINITION, ANY
FORCE THAT CAN TAKE AMERICA'S
NUCLEAR WEAPONS OFF-LINE IS
SOMETHING YOU NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT.
PRESUMABLY THE PENTAGON HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT THOSE.
HAVE THEY GIVEN ANY INDICATION
OF WHAT THEY THINK HAPPENED?
>> WHAT'S I THINK UNFORTUNATE,
AND I GUESS WE ARE AT THE START
OF A PROCESS, THE DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE HAD THIS
REPORT, BUT WHAT IS UNFORTUNATE
IS THE GOVERNMENT DOES KNOW THAT
THERE IS A NUCLEAR CONNECTION.
THEY KEPT THAT CLASSIFIED.
FRANKLY, I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY
SOME OF IT IS CLASSIFIED, BUT
THEY SHOULD COME CLEAN WITH A
LOT MORE THAT THEY KNOW.
I MEAN, THE SIMPLE FACT, THE
U.S. NAVY, WHY DOES THE NAVY
KEEP SEEING THESE THINGS WITH
THE AIRCRAFT CARRIERS?
AIRCRAFT CARRIERS ARE NUCLEAR
POWERED.
WHY DO SUBMARINES SEE THEM?
NUCLEAR CONNECTION.
THIS NUCLEAR MISSILE INCIDENT
FROM THE COLD WAR, THERE IS
CREDIBLE TESTIMONY FROM A GREAT
HISTORIAN ON THIS, ROBERT
HASTINGS, WHO WROTE A BOOK
"UFOs AND NUKES," TO SUGGEST
THE SOVIETS HAD SIMILAR
INCIDENTS.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON, NOT
AMERICA, NOT CHINA, NOT RUSSIA,
AND WE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
INSTEAD OF LAUGHING IT OFF AS AN
ISSUE FOR CRAZY PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT, THERE ARE A
LOT OF CRAZY PEOPLE IN THIS
WORLD RIGHT NOW.
THE PEOPLE WHO TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY MAY BE AMONG THE LEAST
CRAZY IN OUR PUBLIC CON